I think I rushed the end of that problem
just to finish in the 10-minute YouTube
time limit and I just want to make sure
you understand because I kind of did all
over the place we said well you know
white to brown is 2 to 3 and then you
know we just kind of solve for the you
know white is equal to 2/3 times the
brown and we also say well the total
number of baskets the total number the
total gnome in the basket is white plus
brown white is 2/3 of the number of
brown so 2/3 brown plus you know 3/3
brown or you know 1 brown that equals
5/3 brown is equal to the total right or
we could multiply both sides of this
times 3/5 and say that the brown is
equal to the total times 3/5 and since
we can't have a fractional number of
brown eggs the total has to be divisible
by 5 and if we look at the choices the
only number that's not divisible by 5 is
choice B it's 12 all the other choices
are divisible by 5 so they could have
been possible choices let's move on to
the next oh okay there we go and I will
do it in green
7 if 18 root 18 18 times the square root
of 18 is equal to R times the square
root of T where R and T are positive
integers and we also know that R is
greater than T R is greater than T which
of the following can be the value of R
times T R times T so this is interesting
r can't equal T otherwise they would
both they would both be 18 right but one
thing well one one one interesting thing
that we can we can kind of try doing
well actually I'm not I'm not going to
do it that way because I realize that
might be a long way of doing this
problem let's see how could we think
about this problem well we know that R
and T are positive integers so what
could our and T be
18 root 18 so we could factor this more
we could say that this is the same thing
as 18 times you know 9 times 2 in which
case this is the same thing as 18 we
could you know square root of 9 is 3
times 3 times root 2 what's 3 times 18
that's 54 root 2 so this would satisfy
this format so we could say our is 54
and T is 2 in which case our T would be
108 let's see if that's a choice and
it's a choice so we're done because that
could be the value of RT maybe I just
stumbled on it I don't know if there's
other traces and I won't think too hard
about it but that's the answer I just
simplified this a little bit and I said
that's to say 18 root 18 is the same
thing as 54 root 2 and so R is 54 T is 2
if you multiply them you get 108 and
that was choice C problem number 8 which
I will do in yellow
problem number 8 they have a fancy graph
drawn there not a graph of drawing see
the triangle it's one side
one side and then we have another
triangle inside this triangle
hey it's a triangle
another triangle inside that triangle
and let's see what they wrote in
addition to that so this angle is B this
angle is C angle is a this angle is B
this is B and this is a and they want to
know and the figure above what is the
value of C in terms of a and B and I
call this if you've watched my geometry
videos this to me is the angle game
because we're just gonna try to figure
out as many angles as we can and then
eventually we will hopefully be able to
figure out what C is so we know this is
B this is B and all of these combined
form this supplementary angle 180 so we
know that this angle right here is 180
minus B minus B so it's minus 2b right
that's this angle right there and then
what's what's this angle right here
what's this angle well this angle is 180
well now does that help us is that going
to help me with this with this problem
well let's just keep this is 180 minus a
minus C I don't think that that helps us
necessarily this angle right here it's
gonna be 180 minus a minus B right I
should have drawn this bigger this angle
right here is also because we have this
inner triangle right here that also is
going to be 180 minus a minus B this
angle here this this angle here is going
to be 180 minus this angle minus this
angle right so it's 180 minus let me do
it in this color it's 180 minus this
which we figured out was 180 minus a
minus B and we just figured out that
because that was part of this triangle
so it's 180 minus 180 minus a minus B
minus minus this angle here which is
also 180 minus a minus B and it's really
minus two times 180 minus a minus B and
if you simplify that you'll get 180
minus and we have this twice you could
just simplify it so it's two times 180
plus 2a plus 2b I skipped a couple of
steps right because the negative
distributes and then you have two A's
and 2 B's and then if we simplify this
we get C this is 180 minus 360 so you
get 2a plus 2b minus 180 I need to
simplify this is this angle right and
then we also know that this angle that
we just figured out plus B plus C is
equal to 180 plus B plus C is equal to
180 so let me move up here I'm running
out of space so if we want to solve for
C and I don't like this is Purple's too
dark we just subtract everything we
subtract all of this from the other side
right so C is going to be equal to 180
minus 2a minus 2b plus 180 right cuz I'm
subtracting this from the other side or
it'll make it plus 180 minus minus B
again right minus B so if we simplify
this so C is equal to 360 minus 2a and
then minus 3b and let's see if that's a
choice choice E is 360 minus 2a minus
three B so I haven't made a silly error
which I thought it was made so you
really just kind of keep you know you
figure out this angle in terms of a and
B you figure out this angle in terms of
a and B then you figure out this angle
in terms of this angle and this angle so
you just keep using the you know angles
of a triangle add up to 180 property of
triangles go to the next page
oh now we're on the free answer
questions image clear pitch invert
colors all right
so they say I think we have time for
this one 9
they say T to the third is equal to 351
what is 40 to the third so the slow way
of doing this is try to figure out what
T is the fast way is well 42 the third
if T 2/3 is equal to 351 then for T to
the third you just multiply both sides
times 4 and so 351 times 4 4 times 1 is
4 4 times 5 is 20 3 times 4 is 12 1404
that's the answer and I have 40 seconds
left so I'll wait for the next video see
you soon